hello and welcome to this video playing
I so call we have one of my frequent
opponents and one of those guys may I
tend to have good positions that have
spoiled you too technical tricks so I
know how to watch out for the plot and
see you not to do something stupid and
see what we get can we get the banco de
3 gigabytes coaches 6cm okay he declined
the banco with b6 this is an interesting
and system which I'm sephora so it's not
seeing all that frequently I'm can I
baby opt for Bishop to b5 just trade
this bishop on CL is always kind of a
questionable piece if i go here is that
technically interesting okay there's no
reaction from white I can go nighty for
here right and Bishop takes this is the
kind of thing that frequently happens
and against I get some kind of good
position and then it gets messy a do
something stupid so let's see what
happens
Gary takes Bishop c3 pawn takes
critiques are win the rock but it is a
messy position the absolute lame check
hands of creative stuff could happen
hmm
so moving the king I mean it's possible
it's not completely check off so be sure
d 2 was too much 92 it doesn't want to
retreat the night I guess kini to know
my soul goes naughty tuna okay so is
there any sense and playing I'd say we
should find I don't think so i'm just
taking this and now i need to get get my
development going you should f5 you can
take e 7 which is really an issue I
don't know if Queen Queen e5 is a tempo
at least I don't think he can afford to
trade okay so let's do this first remove
the Queen there with the tempo ok Knight
f3 will happen probably but the good
thing is it's not just an exchange of
them also two pawns up and so i can i
can easily give the exchange back for
example let's say the rook here ok but
where do I go with the Queen Queenie for
for Quincy to maybe it looks a bit
strange when you forward other other
squares didn't look more tempting and
Quincy to is somewhat annoying if it
comes ok and I said a queen trade
doesn't really hurt all that much I are
giving back the exchange I mean so this
is made after
okay cannot take them my queen my queen
sir not having a lot of squares for Ruby
19 92 hours a teenage for okay Queen f4
here right it takes a look or no oh no
no no I wanted to go here right attack
the bishop what's going on here the
bishop doesn't have any square white
resigns okay and always kind of dirty
because I've spoiled so many wins
against this guy from similar situation
okay so I don't know about this opening
I don't know if this is a good idea the
idea is just to play Bishop b5 i would
probably even play it ever the porn sack
something like and on this and this just
to get rid of that bishop and in this
particular case he cannot cannot even
win the porn here right for example this
is a tactic now okay went here and now
this is the this is the issue is this
move is somewhat annoying for him a 92
is given by the computer but he played
this in a split second even though 94 is
not exactly difficult yeah I'm not sure
about this maybe it is it is good but
it's certainly and also has some risk
castles is what he wants to do the
engine wants to do that yeah yeah
coupons up to this position but it is it
is somewhat crazy I have not yet
developed this this is the computers
suggestion yeah the computer probably
win is a strong word but probably defend
is quite easily with black but for human
hmm it's not an organism guys gives more
material our channel and objectively now
black is winning is minus 3 according to
the coma I can always screw it up so 97
yeah Queenie for I have to now I just
wanted to trade Queen sir it was
necessary to relieve it I mean this kind
of situation is kind of is nice in
without the dark squared bishop I mean
this piece is not attacking my king and
the night is also not very dangerous so
I don't want to return this exchange so
this no no I can save it and go Ruby one
and i blundered another piece but i
don't think he has much here the rupee
one is Sam it's sorry rupee one is
pretty annoying the engine wants to do
this yeah I mean essentially it's just
the material here exchange in two pawns
okay well thanks for watching